der test auf das corona virus zur
pflicht werden zumindest für urlauber
die aus risikogebieten zurückkehren
das hat gesundheitsminister jens spahn
am montag bestätigt markus j er begrüße
eine solche testpflicht an flughäfen wir
brauchen verpflichtende tests am
flughafen unbedingt und zwar so schnell
wie möglich verpflichtend aber auch
kostenlos und den flughäfen
wir bereiten alles vor jetzt hat wenn
der bund uns die rechtsgrundlage gibt
grundlage der zangs festlandes
infektionsschutzgesetz die verordnung
soll nächste woche in kraft treten
zur kostenfrage gibt es noch keine
einigung zwischen bund und ländern
mehrere bundesländer wollen dass
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten die krone
fest selber bezahlen zum beispiel für
die kosten der flugtickets freiwillige
tests für rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
sind an mehreren deutschen flughäfen
bereits möglich wer keine negativen test
nachweisen kann muss ich für zwei wochen
in quarantäne begeben
zu den risikogebieten gehören unter
anderem die türkei ägypten usa
nordafrika und zahlreiche länder der
karibik risikogebiete werden gemeinsam
von der bundesregierung und dem
robert-koch-institut festgelegt